[Music]
[Applause]
greetings beloved friends thank you for
joining us for our program I'd like to
know as probably most of you know this
is a question and answer program that
airs once a week where you send us your
questions and we do the research and try
to find answers to your questions we
won't always find a satisfactory answer
because there are some things that there
are no answers that we can find but we
appreciate you joining us uh for this
program if you want to send us your
questions you'll find the electronic
address on the screen
TVM tv.org G TVM tv.org we'd be
delighted to receive your questions we
want to remind you that we get many many
questions and uh we are not able to get
to all of them uh in the same program uh
so sometimes it'll be a week or two or
more when we come to the question that
you sent us in its order so please keep
the questions coming and eventually we
will answer those questions I have with
me pastor David Salazar uh who is in
charge of our Spanish work here at
Secrets unsealed um among many other
things uh which I will not mention now
uh he's a jack of all trades and a
master of all so we're very glad to have
you with us thank you Pastor Bor it's
always an honor privilege to share this
time with you and of course answer any
questions from the word of God yeah and
Pastor salad has a wonderful family that
we love too praise the Lord amen okay so
we have many uh very very good question
questions today and we always want to
have a word of prayer before we begin so
would you please pray for us absolutely
let us
pray heavenly father as we come before
you at this hour we thank you for
allowing us to uh search the scriptures
and for having the blessing of the holy
spirit that we can ask and you have said
that you will send it to us so that we
can be guided and be taught by your
spirit into what you have said in your
scriptures so we pray that you will now
give us a portion of that Holy Spirit as
we open your word may your word bring
people closer to you and to the
knowledge of Truth and Lord use us so
that it is you that speak and not man
not us pray all of these in Jesus name
amen amen okay so we have a very very
interesting question uh it has come up
before uh it was sent to us by Peter H
uh doesn't give us where he's sending
this from by the way please let us know
where you're sending the the questions
from uh because we definitely want to
know our reach we want to know how many
people in how many countries are
actually watching our program in which
when we find that there are many of them
it's music to our ears amen uh so the
question is this and I'm going to throw
at Pastor Salasar Yes dear pastors my
question is if the Jewish Nation would
have accepted Jesus how would he have
shed his blood would it
from the high
priest well the question is an
interesting question as you mentioned
and is somewhat of a speculative nature
as as we know that it did not happen
that way unfortunately or the way that
the Bible presents Jesus was going to uh
shed his blood was going to be on a
cross you know in a tree he was going to
be betrayed by a friend and there's so
many other bible promises or proph phes
rather that speak specifically applied
to Christ in the way that he was going
to die uh now had the children of Israel
receive Christ as they were supposed to
maybe the narrative would have been
different the prophetes would have
pointed the different way and most
likely in my humble opinion the the way
that the sanctuary was laid out as a
Plan of Salvation perhaps would have
been followed in that role in in the
sense of perhaps the high priest may
have done something you know but we
don't know that specifically we know
that Christ overall the Salvation was
the lamb that was lay before the EXP
foundation of the world he was in dead
sentence if you will since the very uh
beginning of the Rebellion here on Earth
nevertheless Christ um the important
thing is Christ came to die he had to
die shed his blood in in in the way to
save us from our sins and so um how else
would have happened um biblically
speaking the there is not a a genuine
evidence of how it had happened but uh
we know that the Bible points out to how
it actually did end happening how he was
you know taken to to be you know hit and
and and whipped and and he was bruised
for our iniquities as is say I mentioned
so we know that that's the way that the
Lord sort of knew would happened and he
shared would how how it would have
happened yeah the bottom line is that uh
Jesus had to have the sins of the world
placed upon him right and then he had to
pay the penalty for for sin uh that's
not negotiable whether it would have
been Israel With Tears in their eyes and
pain in their hearts sacrificing Christ
or well whether it was as it actually
took place U the non-negotiable item is
that Jesus had to have s the sins of the
world placed upon him right and he had
to Bear the penalty for for sin uh now
uh there's in Isaiah 46: 9 and 10 uh we
have that which distinguishes the true
God from all false Pretenders right and
I think it Bears a relationship to the
discussion that we're having um do you
want to read that for us Isaiah 46 and
verses 9 and 10 um once again it tells
us what distinguishes the TR true God
from uh all gods that pretend to be God
but they're not really so he says there
the word of God remember the former
things of old for I am God and there is
none else I am God and there is none
like me declaring the end from the
beginning and from ancient times the
things that are not yet done saying my
councel shall stand and I will do all my
pleasure so why is God able to do all
his pleasure for the simple reason that
he already knows right what was going to
happen in the
future uh God did not determine the
future God knew what would happen in the
future and so he maneuvered through
Satan's uh attempted detours right so
that his will would be fulfilled for
that reason we have all kinds of Bible
verses that were fulfilled by Jesus
right at the end of his ministry you
know uh he he said I thirst well that
comes from uh they gave him vinegar to
drink that comes from the Old Testament
on the cross he said why have you
forsaken me that comes from Psalm 22
right uh my friend would betray me you
mentioned that yeah that's found in the
Psalms right uh you know they they uh
cast lots for my garments that comes
from Psalm 22 so God is announcing
before him what was going to happen but
God is Not determining that he's not
saying to to the soul where you know
you're forced to divide his garments and
you're forced to give him vinegar God
knows all of those things we're going to
happen and therefore he can
maneuver uh past all of the uh what
probably would not have been the most
beautiful plan right to fulfill his will
so because he knows the future he is
able to maneuver so that everything is
fulfilled according to his will amen
amen Pastor so anything else no I think
that's pretty clear you know and I think
that's important that we um refrain
ourselves sometimes from kind of
speculating a lot you know what is not
revealed as we can get ourselves into
you know suppositions that may not truly
be conducive to to believing in the word
of God or understanding completely so we
have to be more grounded and rooted in
the word of God and what he has revealed
it's his word and we need to believe and
trust that above everything else when
people ask me what what if Pastor my
answer is it
didn't what if this well it didn't
didn't happen that way so so speculation
is a lot of fun but ultimately you don't
get certain answers yes exactly we have
to be careful with that so okay so the
next question has to do with the
priesthood yes what does it say it comes
from Ronald from Anchorage Alaska and
that's a blessing to know that this
we're being watched in Alaska amen he
says the question Sinners during The
Exodus were required to bring an animal
for various types of offerings to the
Lord with this amount of Sinners and the
complexity of the sacrifice how many
priests were involved daily weekly
monthly or yearly and this is an
interesting question um you have some
some special life that you've been
sharing with me and I'd be interested in
hearing that again well it's a good
question you know I mean but again it's
a little bit more in the you know
there's not a clear find answer in the
Bible as how many specifically uh
priests were involved but one thing that
we can use and I I kind of looked up to
to see what was a moment in time when
they had to use a lot of uh I mean a lot
of priests uh and so we have for example
in the dedication of the Temple of
Solomon when Solomon built the temple
and dedicated to the Lord this is uh is
interesting to know that he had he
offered during that time in in the
Dedication 2 Chronicles chapter 4 verse
one we can actually go there briefly and
we can let the word of God read that um
what was that again 2 Chronicles 4 1
okay second chronicles second chronic 41
and Pastor maybe you can read that if
you get there faster than me yes uh I'm
there okay go for it it says moreover he
made a bronze altar 25 C 20 cubits was
its length 20 cubits its width and 10
cubits its height okay so this is the
size of the the the um the size of the
altar that was built by Solomon and this
is where he we can see that this is
actually a much
bigger altar than the one that uh Moses
erected in the in the Tabernacle the one
in the Tabernacle was actually only
about half of that size actually not a
half five cubits by five cubits so it
was a fourth of that size so when the
Temple of Solomon was built and they
built this massive 20 by 20 cubits um
they they dedicated to the Lord and so
in um and I probably and in the next
verse or the next chapter I can't for
sure remember exactly the verse I missed
it here I forgot to to write it down in
my notes but when he dedicates them he
actually um dedicated
22,000 oxen sacrifice of peace and
120,000 sacrifices of sheep so for two
weeks this is
142,000 sacrifices that they actually
did for two weeks this is the Feast of
uh of the dedication people were happy
they were you know joyful and they had
to
sacrifice this 144
142,000 U uh animals and if you divide
that by 14 days the Bible states that 14
days was the feast you divide that by 14
days and by 12 hours of the daylight you
come roughly to to
850 sacrifices per hour that they had to
sacrifice so for 850 sacrifices to take
place in one hour you are talking that
you need a lot of priests you need a lot
of people it's not just one individual
you know you have a need to have a lot
of people that can come and actually
perform this and this is where we
actually see how in the king uh King
David in in Chronicles 24 uh 1
Chronicles 24 1-5 we go there we
actually see that King David before
Solomon took uh the kingdom or took over
the kingdom we actually see in verses 1
through five the divisions of the houses
of the priests and we actually have in
those five verses we can read how from
Aaron from the PRI of Aaron and then his
he had four Sons now remember that now
that and a were destroyed so they were
no longer partakers of the of the
household of of priesthood we have the
two sons that were elizar and eamar and
out of these two sons we can actually
read that if you actually read Pastor
bour uh verses 1-5 and we can see how
the the priesthood was divided yeah it
says now these are the divisions of the
sons of Aaron the sons of Aaron were
naab Abu elzer and aamar and naab and
Abu died before their father and had no
children therefore elzer in aamar
ministered as priests then David with
zadok of the sons of eleazer and a himik
of the sons of aamar divided them
according to the schedule of their
service there were more leaders found on
the sons of elaser then of the sons of
aamar and thus they were divided among
the sons of elazer were 16 heads of
their of Father's hor houses and eight
heads of their father's houses among the
sons of aamar thus they were divided by
lot one group as another for there were
officials uh there were officials of the
sanctuary and officials of the house of
God from the sons of elar and from the
sons of aamar so 24 divisions as we
mentioned there from the sons of Aaron
24 divisions of the priest families if
you will these were the ones that were
made or organized to partake of all the
items of the T Temple Tabernacle so the
families grew they were not just 4 24
individuals they were actually families
that were part of the priesthood that
needed to attend to all the needs of the
Temple and it abely was you know
probably I don't know hundreds of of of
priests priests that were available
specifically the amount of of priests we
don't have an assurance but uh this is
where I could you know see how it was
divided and how many you know 24
divisions of priesthood and they had to
attend to a lot of in like in the case
of the dedication they had to attend to
850 per hour roughly sacrifices they had
to make and then the rest of chapter 24
gives us the the the courses of the
priests all 24 courses of the priests um
you know it's interesting to read what
flavus Josephus had to say uh this of
course isn't scripture this is from
Antiquities of the Jews book 7 chapter
14 paragraph 7 yeah it says David
divided them also into courses and when
he had separated the priests from among
them he found of these priests 24
courses six 16 of the House of elzer and
eight of that of aamar and he ordained
that one course should minister to God
eight days from Sabbath to Sabbath yes
and thus were the courses distributed by
lot in the presence of David and zadok
and abiathar the high priests and of all
the rulers and that course which came
first was written down as the first and
accordingly the second and so on to the
24th and this partition ha remained to
this day in other words to the days of
Josephus so it was something that lasted
basically during the entire history of
Israel of of course and it's important
you know that we know I mean we don't
have an exact account but at least we
know that there were big families they
had to pertain to a lot of the things
and these were just the priesthood
family the Levites you had also which
were part of the tribe they have the
singers they had the teachers they had
the scribes so they had the whole tribe
was somewhere connected you know one way
or another to the work in the sanctuary
uh or the temple rather but uh the
priest themselves as the question he
says how many priests were involved
daily weekly monthly we exactly that
question is not said in you know it's
not shown in the Bible so we can say
that for sure uh but by this time of
course by the time that Solomon's Temple
was built yeah
um the the number of the people of
Israel had grown exponentially exactly
in other words there were probably
millions in what is called the Holy Land
uh so uh you know there undoubtedly in
each of these families of these 24
courses there were many many who served
in the sanctuary uh we can't answer the
question specifically because there's no
number that is given in the Bible right
as to the number of people now there's
one example in the Bible of an
individual was serving in his course
right of course and this is in the times
of Christ right uh it's it's the uh the
course of abijah mhm it's found in Luke
chapter 1 and let's read verse 5 and
then we'll read verses 8 and N yes uh
it's talking about the father of John
the Baptist he was a priest right this
is uh Luke chapter 5 verse one chapter
one in verse five I'm sorry backwards
one five I have it here five five and
then eight and nine okay it says there
there was in the days of Herod the King
of Judea a certain priest named
Zachariah of the course of Abaya and his
wife was of the daughters of Aaron and
her name was Elizabeth and they were
both rightous before God walking all the
Commandments and ordinances of the Lord
blameless now verse n according to the
custom yeah verse eight and it came to
pass that while he executed the priest's
office before God in the order of his
course according to the custom of the
priest's office his lot was to burn
incense when he went into the Temple of
the Lord so that was the eighth course
if you go back to the Old Testament yes
you see that's course number eight and
so here we have a living example that in
the in the days of Christ right the
orders of priesthood were still being
followed according to what we find in uh
in the book of Chronicles amen that's
important so I think that uh Ronald
maybe gets uh this answer as as hope as
you know we we can encourage him to
continue read the word of God and and
learn more from it amen amen okay we
have another question I think we can
answer this one uh within the time
constraints that we have uh hi Pastor I
greet you in the name of our sooncoming
Savior Jesus Christ my name is
dasas chich chenza from Zimbabwe my
question is is it okay to do Church
board or Elders board meeting on Sabbath
uh so uh how do we say you know about
having a board meeting on Sabbath an
elders meeting on the Sabbath is that
okay or are there problems with it you
know um this question came up a couple
of times when I was pastoring a church
in in Florida and uh the argument for
for many people who felt that it was
okay was well you know we're dealing the
Lord's business we're doing you know the
Lord's work and we can discuss anything
pertaining during the Sabbath day but uh
I particularly remember hearing from
from a an older gentleman who said well
we're talking about secular things many
times things that are not pertaining to
the Sabbath we're not pertaining
necessarily to the church even uh why is
it that we have to do in Sabbath and a
lot of times we said well everybody is
busy working any of their day of the
week blah blah blah and that was the
reason why they said you know we're in
church might as well doing it here and
so the the you know that is uh a
question that I think it's or that
reasoning rather it's probably not not
according to the word of God you know I
think that we need to give the holy of
the Sabbath a time to pertain to things
that uplift and bring us closer to God
and to learn from his word and the
things that are secular because Church
board meetings business meetings even
Elders meetings often times you know
deviate or deal with things that are not
necessarily of of a holy characteristic
and so I believe that unless um you know
it's an emergency meeting where you have
to discuss certain things that IM
immediately attention in regards to the
doctrine or things of the church I
believe that this is not something that
we should be be doing as a practice to
do meetings or board meetings on the
Sabbath day Sabbath they can be six days
of work the Bible speaks of so they
should do it another day of the week
yeah Jesus is our example yeah so when
we go to the gospels how do we find
Jesus observing the Sabbath well Jesus
in the morning is in the synagogue yeah
so that's when we go to church right we
go to church on Sabbath morning we're in
Sabbath School we're in the worship
service but then what do we do in the
afternoon are we sitting in a board
meeting are we sitting in an elders
meeting where perhaps some secular
things are being discussed you know
where where the agenda includes some
items like the business of the church
finances of the church and so on um
Sabbath afternoon is a time to spend
with the family yeah in the midst of
nature studying scripture uh you know
praying visiting the sick visiting those
who are needy encourage them yeah yeah
to encourage them that's what Jesus did
on the Sabbath right and so uh you know
to dedicate Sabbath afternoon to
activities that distract from the way
that Jesus kept the Sabbath is a problem
as far as I'm concerned I agree that we
should not uh have uh board meetings and
we should not have all kinds of meetings
on Sabbath afternoon because we're
supposed to be outside in the midst of
Nature and we're supposed to be visiting
people visiting the sick you know
encouraging those who are discouraged uh
you know sharing the gospel with people
who have not accepted Christ you know
that's what the Sabbath is all about
Isaiah 58 makes it clear sharing you f
food with the hungry sharing your uh
your clothing sharing the clothing with
those who are naked uh you know
encouraging those who are discouraged
and so on uh so um my counsel would be
not to do it on Sabbath and um you know
people use the excus will say it's the
only time that we have free during the
week well that's a problem because
you're not really dedicating the time to
the Lord that you really should be
dedicating to and that's I think the
thing you know is an issue of of selfish
comfort in a sense you know he like you
know I don't have time to dedicate to
the Lord and any other day of week
things that are pertaining to secular
things I think that it's something that
if you're an elder if you are elected to
the board office or to the to be part of
a board meeting you need to make time to
dedicate
time to the Lord as besides you know the
Sabbath which is more as you mentioned
Pastor to the things that pertain to our
spiritual growth family so um you know
there's no thus sayith the Lord except
the fact that we look at how Jesus kept
the Sabbath and uh that would be our
example amen amen well we want to thank
you very much for joining us for our
program today I'd like to know I trust
that it's been a blessing to your
spiritual walk with the Lord may the
Lord bless you and keep you in his care
and we hope to see you in our next
program I'd like to know
[Music]